hello I'm Genji tartikovsky I'm an
animator and director and creator of
Dexter's Lab Samurai Jack Primal and
unicorn Warriors Eternal I'm here to
answer all your animation questions on
Twitter this is animation support
[Music]
at tatsumilology how is 2D animation so
smooth and fluid tell me for animation
we go at 24 frames per second let's say
my arm goes from here to here in 24
frames which is one second so one one
thousand it'll be really smooth if I
don't have the time or money to do it
then I'll start going to 12 drawings and
now all of a sudden it's not as smooth
and then if I really am running out of
money and time then I'm gonna do it
faster and I'm gonna do it in six frames
and here now you're losing the fluidity
but I'm gaining money so I could do the
rest of the episode but it's a fake
nobody cares about fluid or smooth you
want great acting you want good jokes
good stories Good characters if it's a
little choppy I don't care so don't
obsess over smooth or fluidity upsets
over Stories character humor
storytelling at the peach 42 why are
there so many cartoon characters that
don't wear pants that is a old Timeless
question it's haunted me in my dreams
sometimes it's just somebody's choice to
have a character be naked and it's okay
if he has a bow tie on let's keep
thinking about this one all right thank
you
do voice actors try and time their voice
to animation or do animators have to
animate what the voice actors say the
voices come first before the animation
starts we have the actor come in they'll
read the line we edit it into the shot
and then the animator starts to animate
to the lip sync and we break down the
waveform right so it's loud what's
accented and then we'll follow that for
the animation now interestingly enough
for Primal I just have grunting
we did our dialogue recording after the
animation was done Aaron the plant who's
uh who voiced spear he would then come
in we would play him the picture
and then he would do the grunting to the
picture a lot of anime is actually
dubbed sometimes after with the voice
cast but for our style of animation our
mouths are very articulated we have to
do it to the voice recording not after
at least choice or Wise Choice maybe
when they make sequels to animated
movies do animators repurpose shots or
elements of them from the former movies
I don't really know much about animation
so this could be a very stupid question
for Hotel Transylvania from the first
movie to the second movie we repurposed
most of their character designs and the
castle itself but on the other hand
because technology is going so fast
within a couple years imageworks the
studio that we use they reprogrammed all
their tools so they couldn't just use it
they had to input it and then change it
and upgrade it but yeah usually for
sequels unless you change locations
there is some Savings in that at my Ike
camps what are the 12 principles of
Animation basically there's squash and
stretch you have a circle it gets hit by
something and so then it squashes that's
squash and stretch then anticipation
before you can go straight you have to
go backwards for a big cartoony
character doing a punch the anticipation
is crazy so this is a big anticipation
for a punch and then the punch would be
you know completely off the page so
there's your anticipation and there's
your punch and follow through is if you
go to grab something things move at
different speeds so if the hand is
anticipating this way and we're going to
grab then when we move it my wrist will
go first my elbow go back and so you see
the wrist is leading here and then it
catches up after so that's all about
overlapping action and follow through
and you can put the squash and stretch
in there too because then the hand can
be delayed a little bit then there's a
little stretch and really those three
will get you started there are ten maybe
maybe there's eight and I'm not going to
give them to you because they're they're
earned principles that you have to first
learn the first five principles and then
when you get to the eighth principle
sometimes we'll throw in three more
principles and by you know 30 years in
the industry I know 27 principles but
I'm not gonna talk about them because
you can't even comprehend those
principles you know I'm probably gonna
get reamed for forgetting a whole bunch
but you know start with those uh at uh
disorder how often do animators forget
to animate the characters blinking and
how often do we just not notice they
haven't been blinking for like five
minutes blinking is part of keeping a
character alive and sometimes even
breathing that's an odd thing because
it's really creepy because you almost
feel like they are kind of alive we did
that on Fang in Primal where we had her
breathe more because she's such a big
creature sometimes you forget about the
little things and sometimes the little
things say a lot we're always kind of
thinking about it so I usually if the
character is just standing there we'll
always remember to use a blink but a
good observation though uh at slow beef
3D modeling animation question is an
Armature and a rig the same thing
rigging we use the term for
you know what I'm not gonna explain it
it's it's it's hurting my brain an
Armature is basically a skeleton this is
the worst drawing I've done today that's
your Armature but rigging is actually in
CG animation you put a point here and
you put a point here and now your elbow
and your arm can move so that's called
rigging a character for movement and the
Armature is really the proper beginning
to the rigging process it's something I
hate to talk about
[Applause]
uh at Juni by the Sea why is Hotel
transylvania's animation so good hotel
is good because we took the principles
of classical animation stuff that was
done in the 30s and 40s and 50s and we
translated it into CG and what that
means is adding you know new sculptures
to the model and every new expression
and pushing the squash and stretch and
forgetting about gravity and actually
one really interesting thing that
happened was because our animation was
so extreme what happens is you animate
like a naked puppet basically it goes to
a different department and they put the
clothes Dynamics over it the computer
then knows how to fill in the Dynamics
but not when you're moving from here to
here in one frame that doesn't happen in
real life so constantly the closed
Dynamics were broken the animators had
to go back in and actually start
animating the clothes like what how we
would do it on paper and then they would
put those key frames in for the Dynamics
and then they would follow them a little
better everyone would had so much fun I
think doing it because the results were
so unique at I am me essence or I am
Essence a little papa-ish I am the
essence who knows how to create a
cartoon character I like to really think
of a character Inside Out is it a happy
character is it a sad character and then
you're gonna start to find shape
language that suits those personalities
I'm gonna draw it because I like to draw
let's say we're going to draw a happy
character then the posture of that happy
character will usually be uh Happy
arched and there's already a positive
vibe to this character now in the same
respect let's say it's kind of a sad
sacky sad character and the body posture
has to work with the attitude and that's
really the beginning principles of it
all how it all works also once you start
drawing your character they're gonna
start changing it's like having a baby
the baby starts as a pile of mush and
then it starts to tighten up and grow
older and have a personality and all
those things when we we first designed
Dexter Dexter was really tall even
though we knew we wanted them to be
short and as we started drawing him as a
rectangle we do hundreds of storyboards
and we keep going with it all of a
sudden the shorthand he starts to shrink
and he gets squattered right so you can
see the the difference and it's funny
because DD didn't go through the same
transformation I think her torso maybe
got a little smaller we call it pushing
proportions she was kind of like this
right in the first season and then as we
same thing we drew her we drew her we
drew her more and more and more and more
and then she became this
nothing that we really thought about on
purpose but just something that happened
organically so don't be so hard on
yourself and draw the character exactly
the same every time you're going to draw
them give yourself the freedom to get
comfortable with it the character will
become who they organically want to be
without trying to think about it too
much at little Uzi my cousin why are the
Clone Wars Episodes so short the truth
of it is we were really the first ones
to do Star Wars besides like really just
doing commercials and initially George
only allowed Cartoon Network to do one
minute episodes and I said well one
minute is basically a commercial I don't
want to do that I need at least three to
five minutes they went back to George
and George and his son especially I
think like Samurai Jack so they said
we've got Genji and the team from
Samurai Jack but they want more time and
so then George said okay they can have
three to five minutes I think he was
afraid we were gonna mess it up and I
don't blame him because that's like your
baby you know I wouldn't want somebody
else taking it and just doing what they
want with it that's the truth behind the
shortness of those first clone wars at
she ascends why did my parents let me
watch Who Framed Roger Rabbit at such a
young age uh I don't know why I think
it's okay it's not that bad Who Framed
Roger Rabbit helped actually bring back
animation basically around 88 animation
was in really bad shape TV shows are
really bad quality even Disney feature
animation was about to get sold then
they were making Who Framed Roger Rabbit
and it kind of reminded people how fun
animation could be and not only
technically did they blend live action
and animation but they combined Bugs
Bunny and Mickey Mouse together in the
same movie so it felt something more
special and it was great because of it
at Simi Kiera how do you direct an
animated show it's all about having a
point of view and having everybody help
you to create that Vision I was doing
Dexter's Lab we had a an artist would
draw the storyboard we would pinned it
all up and then they would pitch it we
had one storyboard artist when he
pitched the storyboard it was in the
like this funny voice and so Dexter come
over here and then there's DeDe and so
the whole room was crying laughing after
he finished I was like well how the hell
am I supposed to transfer this
performance into this episode because he
doesn't sound like the characters at all
they don't talk like that but there was
something about it that worked and so I
realized oh right that's my job my job
is not to take this performance and
translate it into something entertaining
it was like a really big Epiphany in my
career like all right that's actually
what I do at Twisted Twisted Little Kim
what was your favorite Samurai Jack
episode and why was it the jump good one
it's not the jump good one it's probably
the blind archers one because it's the
first episode that everything worked at
such a high level the story was simple
and super cool the design of it was very
simplistic and great and we did that
thing where we blinded him and it was
black and as the audio came up we
started to see it so it was so artistic
but still had badass action there was
something about it that really clicked
you never want to pick favorites but
that's probably the one that had the
most impact on us at Chris underscore
cull as someone who doesn't work in
animation how often is a storyboard made
like every cut in the scene or is it a
set number of frames generally the whole
rule is every time you cut there's a new
storyboard every time there's a change
of emotion there's a new storyboard
every time anything semi-significant
happens there's a new drawing in the
storyboard our storyboards have now
become basically almost extremes because
the storyboard is so important now we're
drawing more and more panels lucky for
you I have some storyboard examples for
unicorn or Eternal for the first episode
this is a Copernicus who's the robot
coming out of his little grave we'll cut
to the hole and you see his arms come
out
a bunch of steam that comes out and he
starts to lift his body up and he
continues up and now we cut to a
different front angle and he rises up
and then lands and then we start cutting
close and then when I draw this I'll
maybe even break it down even more to a
degree and this you know this is all the
first episode I like to do it like this
first so then I don't get bogged down
with the drawing all the emotion and the
speed and the pacing comes out
storyboards they're the most important
because that's your story it's
everything without a storyboard you got
nothing at the small motion writers
often give Animation notes where do
animators get to submit notes for the
writers
that's a big question in a situation
sometimes a writer has too much opinion
and then the artists don't have as
strong of an opinion but the writer gets
to tell us what to do artists and
storyboard artists are a proud bunch and
we know what we're doing but sometimes
we don't and so we'll forget the writing
we'll throw it away and then we'll do it
on our own and it's equally doesn't work
so usually the healthiest relationships
are the writer and the animator are both
together and they're either unified team
that's why I always write my own stuff
for the most part because I want to have
dual power but yeah usually animation
folks don't get a chance to give writers
critiques we just complain about it at
our desks for three years at qp96 do you
know the difference between animation
and cartoon or should I mind my own
business animation cartoons anime
whatever it's all the same thing but
yeah in the industry especially in
features cartoon uni might have some
negative connotations I love all the old
style of Animation the Warner Brothers
take Savory all that stuff I love to use
the word cartoon it's one of my favorite
words so I think you're good at 95 Vivo
my character design homework is to draw
a cartoon character using the golden
mean
how the I'm not really familiar
with the golden mean I think what it's
trying to say is to be dynamic we used
to say this thing keep the proportions
of the design special if you have a
character you don't want all of the
elements to feel even because this is
just boring what you want is your
elements of the design to be special if
I'm designing a football player you can
design them like a you know human
proportions or
it's it's that and same thing for
composition too usually we think of the
camera broken down into thirds and where
do you put your horizon line if you put
it in the center and then your character
in the center everything is kind of
boring but if you take you know your
horizon line and you lower it and then
your characters on the side here all of
a sudden we've got drama and interest
and scale so when it says your character
design homework is using that principle
it's just big small and medium and think
about it as what's special or unique at
an original username cartoons are better
because you can create a world what
limitations do animators face that they
can't surpass it's all about how well
you draw if you can draw it it can exist
if you can imagine it and you can draw
it it exists so the only things I can't
do are the things that I can't draw and
in my position I'll then find somebody
who can draw those things and they'll
hire them but yeah usually you're just
limited by your drawing ability there is
no limitations and I guess your
imagination well I think that about
wraps it up thank you so much thank you
for all the questions and really thank
you for the last 30 years for watching
all the shows it's super special to me
and I appreciate all your time and thank
you